Nourrir décemment tous les humains et
assurer leur sécurité alimentaire c'est
vital c'est un groupe d'experts du
climat de l'onu
mais à quel prix doit-on faire de crohn
je m'accroche à la planète est déjà aux
prises avec un sérieux problème de
sécurité alimentaire 10% de la
population est sous-alimenté 25% en
surpoids et 30 % des allemands sont
gaspillées de plus l'agriculture
intensive produit le tiers des gaz à
effet de serre et accélère la
dégradation des sols ce qui augmente
encore plus les sécurité alimentaire
avec 11 milliards de bouches à nourrir
si 2005 il faut donc absolument revoir
nos pratiques agricoles mais aussi notre
régime alimentaire il ya de nombreuses
solutions dans le domaine de
l'agriculture que ce soit d'utiliser une
agriculture qui est génératrice donc
éviter les monocultures limiter
l'utilisation d'engrais azotés limiter
le travail des thermes et oui les
protéines animales on en parle beaucoup
c'est parce que c'est là un énorme
impact
en effet la production animale génère
plus de gaz à effet de serre que toutes
autres formes d'agriculture il faut donc
réduire son empreinte écologique
certaines pratiques sont simples à
implanter donc généralement c'est celle
que les producteurs et les plantes en
premier après des investissements qui
sont requis pour changer certaines
façons de faire donc on peut penser à la
gestion dédiée ou des fumiers ou encore
aux pratiques agricoles dans les champs
donc tu veux nécessité des
investissements plus importants mais
comme pour les réductions des gaz à
effet de serre produits par l'automobile
ou la grande industrie
il faudra faire vite parce que les
changements climatiques vont en
s'accélérant
c'est possible ça va prendre des
changements de comportement des
consommateurs mais aussi des politiques
publiques pour pousser ces changements
le monde agricole mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on part pas de zéro
à titre d'exemple on voit de plus en
plus de chaînes de restauration rapide
offrir des menus végétariens et au
québec seulement la production de
produits biologiques a fait un bond de
30% en quelques années ici Normand
Grondin, Radio-Canada Montréal